Alright. Are you ready?
Okay. I am fully aware, in making this appeal
to my much afflicted and suffering brethren,
that I shall not only be assailed by those
whose greatest earthly desires are to keep
us in abject ignorance and wretchedness, and
who are of the firm conviction that heaven
has designed us and our children to be slaves
and beast the burden to them and their children.
I say, I do not only expect to be held up to
the public as an ignorant, impudent, and restless
disturber of the public peace, by such avaricious creatures,
as well as a mover of insubordination--and
perhaps put into prison or to death, for giving
a superficial exposition of our miseries and
exposing tyrants.
But I am persuaded that many of my brethren,
particularly those who are ignorantly in league
with slaveholders or tyrants, who acquire
their daily bread by the blood and sweat of
their more ignorant brethren--and not of a
few of those, too, who are too ignorant to
see an inch beyond their nose, will rise up
and call me cursed--Yea,
the jealous ones among us will perhaps use
more abject subtlety by affirming that this
work is not worth perusing,
that we are well situated, and there is no
use in trying to better our condition,
for we cannot.
I will only ask one question here. Can our
condition be any worse?
Can it be more mean and abject?
If there are any changes will they not be
for the better,
though, they may appear for the worse at first?
Can they get us any lower?
Where can they get us?
They cannot treat us worse, for they know well,
the day they do it they are gone.
But against all accusations, which may or
can be referred against me, I appeal to heaven
for my motive and writing--who knows that
my object is, if possible, to awaken in the
breast of my afflicted, degraded, and slumbering
brethren, a spirit of inquiry and investigation,
respecting our miseries and wretchedness,
in this Republican Land of Liberty.